[موسيقى]
هذا هو موقد المحكمة العليا لدينا ،
كل السحر يحدث داخل
الباكستاني Khazir Imran tajamul توصل
إلى حل موقد طبخ نظيف لا يدخن
ليس فقط موفرًا للوقود
ولكن أيضًا يقلل من تلوث الهواء ،
فنحن نطور مواقد طهي
للمجتمعات والأسر التي
لا  الحصول على الغاز الطبيعي أو
الكهرباء لطهي طعامهم في المنزل كان
خازير وشريكه دانيال
حسين واحدًا من 11000 متقدم للتقدم بطلب
للحصول على منحة من مصدر غير متوقع
expo live في عام 2019 لمساعدتنا
لم نكن نحقق إيرادات كافية
استدامة الشركة ، لذا فقد منحنا معرض إكسبو لايف
مائة ألف دولار من أموال المنح
، وأبقى هذا المال أساسًا على الفريق
واقفًا
على قدميه ، حيث تم إنشاء مبادرة معرض دبي إكسبو 2020 المعروفة باسم
إكسبو لايف قبل خمس سنوات
بمنح تصل إلى خمسمائة ألف
دولار ويبدو أنها تدعم وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
رواد الأعمال من جميع أنحاء العالم
مع حلول منخفضة التكلفة لمواجهة
بعض أكبر التحديات في العالم
مثل الوصول إلى تعليم المياه النظيفة  n
والرعاية الصحية
كنا محظوظين جدًا لأن expo live
كان عبارة عن برنامج تم تكليفه من قبل Expo 220
Dubai بتمويل قدره 100 مليون دولار ،
لذا فقد ولدنا بمهمة نرويها اليوم
في تلك القصة تحتل مركز الصدارة في
المعرض  جناح حي يُعرف أيضًا باسم
المكان الجيد استفاد 5.8 مليون شخص حول
العالم من هذا
البرنامج وهذا يجعلنا نشعر أن هذا يستحق
القيام بذلك وهو أمر يستحق المتابعة وفي الواقع
لا يجب أن يتوقف وهذا هو المكان الذي
نريد الذهاب إليه بعد ذلك
[موسيقى]
نظرًا لأن المزيد والمزيد من الزوار من جميع
أنحاء العالم يتجولون في موقع المعرض ، فإن
هذه المبادرة لا تعمل فقط على
زيادة الوعي العالمي بالتحديات ،
ولكنها أيضًا تخلق إرثًا
يمكن أن يكون للحلول الصغيرة تأثير أكبر بكثير
عليك